[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marble and
it seems like we have some more news on
how Kraven the hunter will be appearing
in the MCU and the upcoming spider-man 3
movie
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down the news everything we know so far
about it and the evidence to back it up
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't seen spider-man far from
home yet and don't want to know what
happens at the end of the film then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
whilst all leaks like this should be
taken with a grain of salt it seems to
line up with what producers in the MCU
are saying so there may be some
legitimacy to it without the way thanks
for clicking the video now let's get
into my breakdown of the wakandan
Kraven the hunter news okay so
spider-man far from home ends on a huge
cliffhanger with Peter Parker having his
identity revealed to the world by Jay
jonah Jameson after Mysterio's forces
hand over doctored footage that makes it
appear as if he was responsible for the
drone attacks in the movie once we never
get any more revelation to the
repercussions that this would cause it's
pretty clear that this would have dire
consequences for the webhead who would
now no doubt be in the firing line of
both friends and foes recently when
promoting far from home directed John
Watts stated the following when asked
about which villains could appear next
oh I would love Kraven it's just the
trick of how you do Kraven in a movie so
it seems like the MCU is eyeing up the
infamous hunted down the line and if the
following rumors are true then we could
be getting him a lot sooner than you
think
the artist boss logic who's created
numerous Marvel renderings and even
correctly reported that Robert Pattinson
would become the new Batman posted to
his Instagram account a rendition of
Kraven with a following caption take
this with a grain of salt so I've heard
from a source that the idea of Kraven
beam from Wakanda from a tribe that no
longer exists due to them being exiled
by the Royals is on the table for the
sake of this post i mocked Mustapha
cashier with somewhat kinder tech but
for the next few days I'll be mostly
dropping San Diego Comic Con posters
honestly this sounds amazing to me and I
definitely think that Kraven would work
as a work
the native from a long exiled tribe work
and in tech would definitely make him a
match for the webhead and it would also
seamlessly tie together two of Marvel's
biggest franchises what's most
interesting about this potential leak is
that Ryan Coogler had originally eyed up
Craven to be the main villain in the
first Black Panther film however that
idea was shut down by Marvel who said
that he wasn't allowed access to the
character just yet with Black Panther
becoming such a big success I could
definitely see the studio now granting
access to Kugler and letting him perhaps
begin to sell the seeds with the
character in Black Panther 2 that could
come to fruition in future spider-man
movies obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these leaks and if you think
that this take on Kraven would be good
or not comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the recent Robert Downey
jr. interview which goes over the most
heartbreaking thing about Tony Stark's
armor in Avengers end game I'll leave
that linked at the end and hopefully
I'll see you over there after this I
also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
Avengers and game on blu-ray to one
lucky winner and all you have to do is
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on this Craven news in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on August the 10th
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
there to ever get surprise so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you